étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique
]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va tuer des gars
[Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
oh
merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [Applaudissements] [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [Musique]
hey baby baby
[Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
étranger
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements]
euh [Applaudissements
]
chansons de messieurs
images de messieurs et synovations de messieurs [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique
]
lieux
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
étranger
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique] [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Musique]
whoa
I'll stand for me
[Musique] [Musique
] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
Je suis calme
[Applaudissements]
oh ça va bébé
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
étranger [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements]
étranger [Musique]
[Musique]
étranger
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenez enfoncé maintenez
[Ap  applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'accord